Mary Barnstead is here from the National
Education unit I wonder if I could just
pick up on that point though as well I
mean we take for granted don't we the
fact that women and kids women girls can
be educated here in the UK we absolutely
do and when you hear of what's happening
in Afghanistan uh I saw a
um on Twitter recently about a
seven-year-old girl saying don't you
care about your mothers don't you care
about your sisters
um and women in Afghanistan are now
being told I hear that um they can't see
a male doctor I mean it's the the scale
and the extent of the repression is
astounding I think
we were chatting uh recently Mary
actually you were very good enough to
come in when we did our ask the union
leaders and you answered questions from
our viewers I suppose a question that
they would want me to ask you today is
do you expect your members to go on
strike
well we'll know at five o'clock today
um we we haven't had the result from
when we take a formal ballot for strike
action we have to use an independent
polling company quite rightly by law so
that the vote is
um uh absolutely legitimate and in order
to take strike action we have to pass
very high thresholds 50 of the members
have to vote and
um 40 of the hull membership the
equivalent of 40 of the home ownership
have to vote Yes so if at five o'clock
today we find that the members have
voted it will be that half the members
have voted during a time when there was
postal disruption and 80 of those
members need to vote Yes before we can
take
strike actions so these are these are
thresholds which are very high and if
they are reached
um and it would be the first time I've
been a general secretary since 2003.
it'll be the first time that we had a
valid anything like this extent and
scale and the first time of a national
ballot for pay at this level so it's an
Indica it's an indication of how
strongly members are feeling sure I mean
you know what your members are thinking
though don't you what do you think
I from our own internal polling I I
think that we will meet the thresholds
but I can't be sure and I really can't
be sure I'll know about two o'clock
today and what are the big issues for
your members the biggest issue is that
there is a Workforce crisis in our
schools and those aren't my words those
are the words of Amanda Spillman the
Chief Inspector of schools she wrote in
her annual report in December 2022 that
school leaders are finding it the most
difficult thing for them to do is
recruit and retain staff and that this
was leading and these are her words to a
Workforce crisis in schools and children
were bearing the brunt of that crisis
and it's quite interesting I mean I can
give you all the figures about the
number of teachers leaving the
profession I can tell you that
um the government only recruited just
over half of its targets for secondary
teachers this year just recruited 61
percent
um so we're nearly 40 short of the
Target for secondary teachers but this
becomes really apparent because I now
have parents writing to me and last week
I had a parent contact me who said my
son is in year 11 doing GCSE chemistry
the three chemistry teachers in the
school have left since September he's
been using worksheets it's being taught
by cover teachers using work worksheets
how is this preparing him to take a GCSE
in chemistry and and just yesterday a
parent
in a primary school her child is in year
four her child has had 20 different
Supply teachers all doing the best job
they can but no regular teacher since
September and parents up and down the
land will be when I say this that will
you know many many many of them will
have had that experience one in eight
maths lessons is now taught by a
non-subject specialist so the other
thing that's happening in schools
particularly secondary schools is that
um there's an army of teachers doing the
best job they can but teaching out of
their subject area in some schools it's
about half the lessons
um some of the time when teachers are
teaching out of their subject area and
however hard they work they cannot
provide the quality of Education that
children and young people deserve so if
my members take this action it is with a
heavy heart and it is because they feel
that they have not been listened to and
they have no other choice can you
reassure my viewers this morning that
there will not be strike action during
the exam period I think that that would
be very unlikely I don't think teachers
would do that or want to do that I mean
I can't really out I have an executive
but my strong feeling is that that
wouldn't be done and even if there was
dry catching on an exam day actually
they would be covering for the children
to do the exams and all the work has
been done prior to that but I think
that's a huge step and I think it's
highly unlikely we know that there's a
national day of action call for by the
TUC on the 1st of February if you get
your results today that would take you
just under the wire with a two weeks
notice that you have to give would that
be something that you would be
encouraging your members to take part in
well we will declare the pattern if we
make the thresholds and we'll know at
five o'clock tonight we will declare the
pattern of action then I can't really
reveal that but obviously if we do that
we would just get under the wire for the
first of February is that something you
would look at yes it is absolutely and
that being the case I have a direct
message to the government now they have
known the government has known that we
have been balloting on them as we did in
We did an internal ballot in November
that came out very strongly for strike
action they didn't call us in to discuss
this or to negotiate I didn't get one
whole from the Secretary of State for
Education they've known you've had a lot
sorry you've had a lot of secretary I
have there's a lot but but no call from
the Secretary of State we were called in
they've known we were doing a formal
ballot all the way through December and
the first two weeks in January we were
called in for the first time on the 9th
of January for an hour's meeting with
the secretary of state now that is not
serious negotiation we uh conversation
go with Julian well it was perfectly
Pleasant and perfectly cordial but it
achieved nothing I mean it did you talk
about money no what did you talk about
we talked about
um
that education was very important and
that teachers are very important and we
talked a bit about inflation and we
counted the argument that wage Rises are
causing inflation because when they're
running at less than half the rate of
inflation they're clearly not but no we
didn't talk about money and we didn't
talk about money either for this year or
next year of course we did and we asked
directly what you know what is the
possibility is that what you said yeah
we said well what's what's on the table
for this year and what what and you know
how could we explore other ways in which
um we could get a deal for example
bringing forward pay
um the pay award for next year which
doesn't start until September this year
which doesn't start until September so
we try to explore a whole range of
issues but frankly we were told it was
unlikely there would be any more money
this year and we asked directly I had
another meeting with officials on Friday
and I said okay so what's the what are
you going to be telling the review body
is Affordable for next year and was told
that they couldn't tell me that yet now
this isn't good enough we're serious
people we want to go in and do serious
negotiations because the last thing my
members want to do is take strike action
not only do they lose a day's pay but
they lose a day in school and they are
dedicated professionals dedicating to
teach the children that they serve but
it but they are at the end of that ever
what would you say to parents this
morning though who rely on schools to
keep their children warm and safe while
they go to work to try to earn a living
in this cost of living crisis I would
say our argument isn't with you our
argument isn't with you but what should
they do with their kids well I mean they
will that is very very difficult for
them many will have family who will make
arrangements but some of people will
have to take a day off work in order to
look after their children and we really
zero hours contract they're going to
lose money yeah I know we are really
sorry about all of that we do not want
to Target you we do not want to Target
your children but when we have
um a teacher Workforce crisis when you
as parents know that your children are
routinely not being taught by regular
teachers not being taught by teachers or
qualified in the subject they are
teaching when the government this year
is 23 down on its teacher training
figures than it was last year when 40 of
teachers leave within 10 years driven
out by overwork and underpay when
teachers have lost nearly a quarter of
their salary in real terms since 2010
when no one you know when government
cannot get teachers to join the
profession and can't get teachers to
stay in the profession in the end that
becomes unsustainable and that's where
we are now and if I all thought to those
who would dismiss that and say teachers
get six weeks off in the summer a month
off at Christmas two weeks off in April
as my mum would say your bum's in butter
well
um teachers work the longest hours of
unpaid overtime of any profession that's
um
you know teachers for example primary
teachers teach about 21 22 hours in the
classroom spend another 35 hours on
average working so these are 55 hours 60
hour working weeks secondary teachers
about the same
um they work the most unpaid overtime of
any profession and anybody who knows a
teacher or anybody who's got to teach in
the family knows that they work harder
than anybody else in that family so and
when teachers get that you know this six
weeks business they might take three
weeks holiday they spend the rest of the
three weeks preparing for um going back
in September when they get to half term
many teachers are lie in bed exhausted
and Ill because they've just made it
through through I mean teachers have
seen the greatest degree of work
intensification of any profession that's
and and so you know teachers work very
hard yeah I was overhearing a
conversation over lunch actually
yesterday uh people sat on the table
next to me and and the gentleman had a
young baby with him his wife was a
teacher the child was about a year old
old and his wife was struggling with her
mental health because of the challenges
that she had at being a teacher yeah
teachers have soaring rates of Mental
Health
and the pressure is always on them we
have to we have to recreate teaching as
a profession which is doable which is
enjoyable where people work hard but
they have the right to have time away
from their work and we have to pay
teachers properly for the work they do
we can't carry on with lowering teacher
pay relative to society and expect our
education system to work and it's not
working at the moment okay thanks for
coming in again really appreciate it
thank you thank you you'll know at five
o'clock this evening how will you make
that announcement uh it's on Facebook
it's on YouTube and it's on Zoom so
um people can tune in to that
announcement and it's on the NAU Twitter
line you can get the feed to the live
allowance is that when you find out or I
find out a bit before but I would have
to you'd have to kill me if I were to
tell you I won't do that and it's good
to see you thank you thanks very much
indeed